cuando era niño creciendo en guatemala
tenía una idea que estaba seguro era
totalmente genial y me voy a ser
multimillonario lo que quería hacer era
tener un gimnasio donde todas las
máquinas de hacer ejercicio todas las
bicicletas estacionarias las máquinas
elípticas todas iban a estar conectadas
a la compañía eléctrica
y lo que vamos a hacer era transformar
toda la energía cinética de las personas
que estaban haciendo ejercicio a energía
eléctrica y se las vamos a vender a la
compañía eléctrica es lo que quería
hacer y aún más y aquí vamos a hacer
dinero vendiendo la energía a la
compañía eléctrica no teníamos por qué
cobrarle a las personas por ir al
gimnasio entonces va a ser un gimnasio
que va a ser totalmente gratis y por
esto iba a poder monopolizar todo todos
los gimnasios del mundo porque va a
tener una cadena grandísima de gimnasios
totalmente gratis donde las personas
generaban electricidad y lo que iba a
tener una megacorporación donde millones
de personas iban a generar electricidad
para todo el planeta de una manera
sostenible y por supuesto saludable
ahora resulta ser que esta idea se le
ocurrió a miles de personas y además ni
siquiera funciona
y que hay dos razones por las que no
funciona la primera es porque los
humanos somos malísimos para generar
electricidad no generamos muchos
entonces no hubiera podido hacer mucho
dinero con esto y la segunda aún más
importante es que los gimnasios hacen la
mayoría de su dinero a través de
personas que pagan la suscripción pero
nunca van
entonces esto no hubiera funcionado pero
esta plática es acerca de cómo esta idea
que se le ha ocurrido a miles de
personas y que ni siquiera funciona
puede ser utilizada para completamente
revolucionar la educación a nivel
mundial
hace alrededor de 4 años empecé a
trabajar en el en mi último proyecto que
es un sitio de aprendizaje de idiomas
que hoy en día es la manera más popular
de aprender idiomas en el mundo que se
llama duolingo
cuando empecé eso es lo que quería hacer
era empezar a trabajar en algo que
realmente me trajera pasión y en mi caso
esta es la educación ahora mis opiniones
acerca de la educación tienen mucho que
ver de el hecho de que soy de guatemala
guatemala es un país muy pobre
se dice que la educación es algo que
trae igualdad a las diferentes clases
sociales pero a mí siempre me pareció lo
opuesto especialmente viendo la realidad
guatemala y siempre me pareció que la
educación realidad es igualdad a las
diferentes clases sociales porque las
personas que tienen dinero se pueden
pagar la mejor educación del mundo los
mejores tutores los mejores libros y van
a educarse a harvard y después ya que
tienen tan buena educación siguen
teniendo dinero las personas que no
tienen mucho dinero apenas aprenden a
leer y escribir ya que casi no saben ni
leer y escribir se quedan sin tener
mucho dinero entonces lo que yo quería
hacer era tener a hacer algo con la
educación que le diera igual acceso a la
educación a todos sin importar su clase
socioeconómica ahora la educación es
algo demasiado general para mí entonces
decidí enfocarme en un tipo de educación
y es algo que es muy común en la mayoría
de los países del mundo y es aprender
idiomas es muy común casi todos los
países del mundo esta es una de las
cosas más comunes de aprender a
excepción de los gringos ahí no aprenden
otros idiomas
pero en el mundo alrededor de 1200
millones de personas se están
aprendiendo otros idiomas ahora es un
mercado bastante interesante la mayoría
de estas personas 800 millones de ellos
satisfacen tres propiedades la primera
es que están aprendiendo inglés la
segunda es que la razón por la que están
aprendiendo inglés es para obtener un
mejor trabajo y la tercera es que son
personas de bajo nivel socioeconómico sé
que la mayoría de personas que están
aprendiendo idiomas son gente pobre que
está aprendiendo inglés para poder salir
de la pobreza ahora lo irónico es que
hasta hace cuatro años la mayoría de
maneras de aprender idiomas
especialmente constructor costaban mucho
dinero por ejemplo en eeuu hay un
programa que se llama nuestra trust
aunque cuesta entre 500 a 1000 dólares
para aprender idiomas en latinoamérica
está open english que cuesta alrededor
de 1000 dólares para poder aprender
idiomas pero lo irónico es esto la
mayoría de estas personas están tratando
de salir de la pobreza pero
aparentemente para poder salir de la
pobreza se necesita tener mil dólares
entonces decidí que lo que quería hacer
era una manera de enseñar idiomas que
fuera totalmente gratis
si quiero tener una manera de enseñar
idiomas que sea totalmente gratis y le
quiero llegar a 1200 millones de
personas
tengo encontrar una manera de financiar
esto entonces en eso me puse a rezar
cómo podemos financiar
algo para enseñar idiomas enseñarle a
mil millones de personas idiomas
totalmente sin cobrarles y ahí fue dónde
surgió otra vez la idea el gimnasio
recuérdense con el gimnasio podríamos
ofrecer el servicio totalmente gratis
porque estábamos obteniendo valor de
cuando las personas hacían ejercicio
será que podemos hacer lo mismo a la
hora de que estamos enseñando idiomas y
resulta ser que sí que lo que podemos
hacer cuando las personas están
aprendiendo idiomas es que podemos
generar valor a través de traducción
resulta hacer que la traducción es un
negocio grandísimo se gastan albert de
30 mil millones de dólares al año
traduciendo cosas por ejemplo
traduciendo noticias o traduciendo
internet ofreciendo libros se hacen
alredor de 30 mil millones de dólares al
año
ahora si alguna vez han aprendido algún
idioma algunos de los ejercicios que
tienen que hacer cuando están
aprendiendo o para practicar es muchas
veces traducir cosas sencillas por
ejemplo traducir una canción o traducir
un poema pero qué tal si estuvieran
traduciendo algo que nunca nadie ha
traducido y que alguien está dispuesto a
pagar por que lo traduzcan esa es la
idea de duolingo y así es como se
financia duolingo entonces por ejemplo
cnn es uno de los clientes de ningunos
otros clientes y la idea es que ellos
escriben todas sus noticias en inglés
después nos mandan las noticias
a nosotros y de ahí nosotros escogemos
algunos alumnos de domingo que están
aprendiendo inglés y les decimos y
cuando acaban de terminar una lección
que les enseñamos algo les decimos si
quieren practicar lo que acaban de
aprender con algún documento del mundo
real aquí está esta noticia de cnn que
está relacionada con lo que quedan de
aprender y para practicar ayúdenos a
traducirla a su idioma natal y entonces
entre ellos la traducen y se corrigen
los unos a los otros y después resulta
una traducción entera y se la regresamos
a cnn y ellos nos pagan por esta
traducción esa es la manera en que
funciona duolingo hace alrededor de dos
años y medio
lanzamos la plataforma que es una página
web también una aplicación de iphone y
una aplicación de android y hoy en día
tenemos 42 millones de personas
aprendiendo idiomas a través de edu o
link o es la plataforma más popular de
aprender idiomas y es más por ejemplo en
eeuu hay más personas en eeuu
aprendiendo idiomas a través del
bullying o que en todo el sistema de
educación pública de eeuu
ahora esta idea de esta idea del
gimnasio de cómo financiar la educación
pareció muy innovadora pero realmente es
muy parecida a cómo funcionaba funcionó
la educación por miles de años hasta
hace relativamente poco tiempo
que era el modelo del aprendiz hace
digamos hacia el mejor de 300 años si
alguien quería aprender algo por ejemplo
si querían aprender a ser panadero o
carnicero lo o lo que sea lo que hacían
era encontrar a alguien que ya sabía
hacer eso por ejemplo no trabaja un
panadero un carnicero y se volvían
aprendiz de ellos
y la manera que funcionaba es que el
maestro por ejemplo el carnicero le
enseñaba al alumno a cómo hacer
carnicero y
de intercambio el intercambio era que el
alumno ayudaba al maestro con su trabajo
eso era la manera en que funcionaba la
educación
y esto es muy parecido a cómo funciona
duolingo en el caso de domingo los
alumnos no pagan con dinero si no pagan
con algo que genera valor que es la
traducción ahora
este modelo del aprendiz casi se fue por
completo cuando vino la revolución
industrial porque lo que se tenía que
hacer era enseñar en la misma cosa a
cientos de diferentes personas y esto
simplemente no se podía hacer con
aprendices y con maestros así porque no
era escalable pero el modelo de aprendiz
tiene bastantes cosas muy positivas por
ejemplo una de ellas es que no hay
intercambio de dinero el alumno no paga
con dinero y así esto le da igual acceso
a cualquiera no importa si tiene mucho
dinero si tien poco dinero cualquiera
puede volverse un aprendiz eso es muy
bueno la otra cosa es que el maestro
tiene mucho incentivo para enseñarle
bien el alumno porque el alumno va a ser
parte del trabajo del maestro entonces
él es lo mejor que puede hacer el
maestro es esencial enseñarle bien pero
para mí
el efecto positivo más grande del modelo
del aprendiz es que es muchísimo más
eficiente desde el punto de vista de
eficiencia social póngase a pensar en lo
siguiente
hoy en día todas las personas que están
aprendiendo algo por cierto la mayoría
de personas en muchos miles de millones
de personas en el mundo pasan alredor de
20 años yendo a la escuela aprendiendo
cosas la mayoría de ese tiempo no están
ayudando a la sociedad en lo más mínimo
simplemente están estudiando mientras
que con el modelo del aprendiz el
aprendiz estaba haciendo algo positivo a
la sociedad estaba ayudando a la
sociedad
pero hoy en día durante todos esos 20
años todos los ejercicios de matemática
que hicieron todos los programas de
computadora que hicieron cuando estaban
aprendiendo todas las investigaciones
científicas los ensayos que escribieron
todo eso literalmente se bota a la
basura todo ese esfuerzo mental lo
estamos botando a la basura es un
desperdicio
en inglés hay un término para esto se le
dicen masturbación mental es lo que se
le dice en inglés esto es un desperdicio
total entonces lo que yo quisiera es que
todas las personas que están estudiando
pudieran generar algo positivo a la
sociedad en mi sueño es que hayan
millones de niños en todo el mundo en
países subdesarrollados trabajando de
gratis para mi a nuestra zona mal perdón
pero ustedes me entienden es lo que
quiero hacer ahora los quiero dejar con
la siguiente pregunta
este modelo del gimnasio es unidad que
se le ocurre a muchas personas si no
funcionan pero puede ser transformado
para generar mucho valor en él en
términos de educación la pregunta es en
qué otros ámbitos se puede usar este
modelo muchas gracias